and another other roles i hear that you
turned down like did you ever meet with
stanley kubrick on full metal jacket i
did man you met with stanley i didn't
meet with him but i had a couple calls
with him it's an interesting story so
i'm doing weird science and i get a call
from my agent a gentleman named marty
bauer it's a great guy
uh marty started the bauer benedict
agency which became another big agency i
think uta right
so as a kid he represented me he was
like family i love marty so he calls me
like on a wednesday he says stanley
kubrick is interested in you in this uh
for a role in this vietnam biopic he's
doing and i was like holy [ __ ] because
even at 17 i'd seen the shiny and all
these great women oh yeah
so i get a call friday two days later he
goes well he's actually wants you for
the lead and he wants to call you
tomorrow
mike dropped right i'm like holy [ __ ]
kubrick's gonna call me
it's like wait for the wizard of oz
right
so the next morning the phone rings
and i'm like up at pace i'm at the
sheridan premiere up by the universal
city and i'm up like pacing like i'm
just wet going i can't believe i'm
talking how old are you i'm 18.
uh the phone rings
michael stanley kubrick i was like
and then this is what he said to me he
paid me the greatest compliment i've
ever had he was like i just finished uh
screening 16 candles i watched it three
times i couldn't believe it i'm just
sitting here
and he goes like you know you're my
favorite actor since i saw jack an easy
rider i was like dude
i'm a kid yeah no exactly he said that
to me so that it was amazing it was
astonishing michael it was
and then even more you know beyond that
wonderful compliment he wound up talking
about his favorite filmmakers he started
talking about eisenstein the great
russian director and chaplain and
dude you're just sitting there listening
i'm standing there in the sheridan
premiere like looking over the valley
like in my window
and i was just bugging out it was
incredible so
what happened was it became literally
like an eight or nine month negotiation
holy [ __ ] yeah and it was you know it
was i could say in hindsight it was
about money but it wasn't it was just a
crazy drawn out thing
he was incredibly private i had to go to
his attorney's house in beverly hills
and read a numbered script i mean
literally dude it was like this wow
and you know for whatever reason didn't
work out and and
and that's another great film of his so
i mean i wouldn't have any regrets in my
life i don't but in terms of a creative
thing that's probably the closest thing
that it just breaks my heart sometimes
that it didn't work out he needed to
work with him but right do you think
maybe
got in the way
no no no no it wasn't even like that it
was just we just kind of parted ways but
i couldn't believe it took that long at
one point nine months no no i swear to
you at one point he called his lawyer
and his lawyer called my father who was
a great manager
he discovered like azamo and sandra
bullock and all these people he was a
great manager tom
and the question that louis blau had for
my father was
mr kubrick wants to know if tom has read
nuclear negotiations
a book called nuclear
kubrick was deep dude everything was
chess
everything was nuclear
i swear to you i swear to you so
so anyway i mean i i would have loved to
have done that and then it's funny
little epilogue i run into matthew
modine a couple years later
in new york city and i'm still a kid you
know and he was
he was kind of big league of me he was
funny
how you doing modinia cool
and then i started walking alongside him
in new york and we're talking i go so
how long do you guys wind up shooting
that film you know
tell me vision quest i want to know
and uh he goes i swear to god he goes 54
weeks
54 weeks he shot for a year and two
weeks wow
but he was just brilliant and he had
that
capacity and and that allowance within
our industry i mean the very few people
how long should have filmed that long i
think not since chaplain you know
because chaplin was notorious that in
that day of the max senate days he would
shoot something and if he ran out of
ideas he would just break camp you know
right and chaplain would notify you when
he had some ideas for stunts you know
but stanley cooper what can i say man i
just bowed out i love stealing kubrick